[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I have a totally cool
video for you I did a top-10 deku fact
in the past and that did really well and
you guys seem to enjoy it so I thought
it was about time to make another one
today we are going to be looking at one
of my favorite characters and best girl
in my hero academia to you ah sweet AKA
rainy season hero fra p if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe in
united states of smash that notification
bell so you never miss a new my hero
academia video also if you like these
kinds of videos be sure to oklahoma
smash that like button to let me know
comment below which character in MHA you
want me to look at next and it may be
the next video i do you can also let us
know on instagram and twitter where
you'll find plenty more MHA content and
discussion now i know i may have
triggered some people earlier by calling
frothy best girl in my hero academia
because there are so many great options
for best girl in this anime but frothy
is nonetheless my favorite and i'm not
alone in that regard which brings us to
fact number one fra p is a popular
character more popular than you may have
thought - you got sixth place overall in
the first japanese poll and she was the
second most popular female character
after or chuckle this is no small
accomplishment in an anime with so many
awesome likable characters in the second
Japanese poll - you got ninth but again
she was the second most popular female
character after Jiro this time however
the third and most recent Japanese poll
released December 11 2007 teen who did
not make the top 20 so - has been a
pretty popular character in Japan
although her popularity seems to be
slipping however interestingly enough in
the u.s. fra P is even more popular in
the first US popularity poll so you came
in second only losing out to deku while
in the second poll so you came in fifth
she placed lower than one female
character hemoccult toga
who got third place but fifth is still
pretty damn impressive it is also
noteworthy that crunchyroll ran a my
hero academia a popularity contest in
2018 and with almost 40,000 votes they
boasted that it was the most voted mhm a
popularity poll of all time in this poll
- you also ranked high at fifth place
under or chico almighty Todoroki and
deku additionally on our instagram at
anime uproar i asked you guys to go for
best girl and the results were close
portugal was right behind momo and to
you who both got 10 votes but my vote
puts you over the top with 11 sorry to
the momo fans but let me know if you
want a momo faq video in the future I
already got the thumbnail made for that
one if you're interested you can still
go to that post and vote or just write
who you think is hashtag best girl in
the comments below this video
but yeah Tropius evidently quite a
popular character especially in the u.s.
by the way let me know in the comments
why you think she might be more popular
in the US I'd be interested in hearing
your hypotheses about this FRA P is so
popular in the u.s. that there was an
article I'll link it in the description
devoted to to you and declared her the
breakout star of anime in 2017
the article also included tweets of
people who clearly love FRA P one
commentator says he doesn't know what
vnh a is but he's in love with the Frog
girl another says that he hasn't read
mh8 but that he would already die for
frog girl and another says he take a
bullet for her so twos fans reach beyond
even viewers of the show which is crazy
to think about
however despite her immense popularity
she was close to not being a character
in my hero academia which brings us to
vac number 2 along with toaru kagaku rey
and may hots may sue you was originally
supposed to be a male character but the
class had too many boys so horikoshi
changed these three into female
characters instead
horikoshi says
he's glad he did and I'm sure that most
of us are also extremely thankful for
these changes
hatsune and to you in particular are
very popular and many fans would argue
that one or the other is best girl so
it's crazy to think they might not have
been girls at all Toru is invisible so
her character design is probably not
much different but her personality might
have been along with changing her gender
horikoshi also made tools designed more
frog-like emphasizing her froggy
features for instance he made her eyes
and mouth bigger
she was also supposed to be more of a
downer perhaps she would have been
saying everything was a drag like
Shikamaru but what he caught she decided
to make her more upbeat there are some
cool fan arts of what's whose initial
male design might have looked like but I
think we all preferred a final to you
and I know that Mina Todd definitely
does in fact number three it should come
as no surprise that horikoshi drew
inspiration from western comic books
especially Marvel Spiderman was one of
his big inspirations but I think the
Marvel comic that is most reminiscent of
my hero academia is x-men except
mutations are called quirks instead in
x-men there is a character called toad
that likely inspired horikoshi at least
as far as powers went forty course she
also might have been thinking of making
to you a male character because toad is
himself a male character there are many
things in common with sujes and toads
powers this includes their extraordinary
leaping agility their ability to extend
their long tongues and use them in
combat and so on sue you superhero
costume even has goggles as some
versions of toad do
despite their similarities let me be the
first to say that I definitely prefer
horikoshi she's character design now
let's just hope to you stays away from
lightning you know what happens to it
when it's struck by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else fact number four to you
is the shortest girl in class 1a she is
150 centimeters tall or 4 foot 11 inches
nonetheless there is a shorter character
the one the only the oh so perverted
Moneta who comes in at only 108
centimeters or three foot six and a half
inches Minetta to you and mezzo Shoji
form team Anita during the cavalry
battle of the you a sports festival
since Shoji is actually the tallest
character and many times who you are the
shortest they use their respective sizes
to their advantage by having Moneta ends
who you use Shoji's arms as cover while
they launch surprise attacks against the
others fact number 5 to you is smart
smarter than you might have thought she
scored 6th in class 1a midterm rankings
just behind Todoroki and deku two other
intelligent characters in fact according
to the official data book for my hero
academia to you along with Todoroki and
deku are in a similar neighborhood when
it comes to their respective
intelligence levels since they all
scored 4 out of 5
however perhaps to your surprise all
three lose out to Moneta who scored a
very impressive 5 out of 5 while we're
at it I'll show you guys all up to you
stats compared to another common best
girl choice or choco Urraca by the way
for some reason I really wanted to
create bar graphs for this video so I
did let me know if you found them
helpful back to 2 stats she scored a 1
in power 3 and speed foreign technique
for in intelligence and 5 in
cooperativeness thus you can see she
beat out or choco in speed and
intelligence fact number 6
according to horikoshi to you has a
cat-like posture yes in the manga what
eco she offers us some character
profiles every once in a while and
they're cool because they usually give
us information which you may not get in
the manga or anime even if you're
reading the manga these details can
easily be overlooked so I wanted to make
sure to talk about to use interesting
character profile as I mentioned even
though her quirk
is called frog form she actually has a
cat-like posture along with that she has
big feet and hands and interestingly
enough a mysterious hairstyle this
character profile also reveals that too
is working on mastering and camouflaging
ability and that she has a weakness to
cold weather which renders her unable to
use her quirk all she can do is repeat
the words I'm sleepy in such scenarios
fact number seven in the original
Japanese drop is voiced by a 26-year old
ally yeah boo sake also known by her
stage name Ally Yuki Yuki was also in
other massively popular anime in the
seven deadly sins she voices Deann aka
the scent of envy and in one punch man
she voices Tatsu locky aka tornado of
Terror evidently she's got an exquisite
record for voicing best girls fun fact
Yuki is even shorter than Sue you the
shortest female in class 1-a coming in
at only 145 centimeters or 4 foot 9
inches fact number 8 in the English dub
to you is voiced by the 42 year old
Texan Monica rial she also has quite an
impressive and sizable record of
performances including Bulma and John
Ball super and Sakura and the new
Cardcaptor Sakura anime when she was
young Monica's family used to visit
Spain frequently and she would translate
anime from the Spanish dub into English
for her brother impersonating the
characters to one of the anime she
translated for her brother was Dragon
Ball Z so it's cool to consider how she
would eventually get the opportunity to
voice Bulma for an entire Western
audience let me know which voice actress
you prefer for to you in the comments
fact number 9 what eco she posts my hero
academia sketches on his Twitter every
so often a lot of these drawings
featured who you dressed in unique
outfits that you usually don't get to
see in the anime mode eco she drew her
in a dress kimono
swimsuit but Google's hero costume
zeroes hero costume and my personal
favorite a vampire nurse costume also
she is featured alone with Baku go in
some of the sketches
so I don't know if horikoshi is hinting
at something here hmm let me know who
you would ship to you with in the
comments PS this Q picture shows that
tsuyu does in fact have five toes even
though her hero costume makes it look
like she has only three fact number 10
tsuya was born on February 12th which
makes her an Aquarius aka Water Bearer
whose birthday and horoscope definitely
complement her character in addition to
being associated with water which makes
sense for a frog
Aquarius born people are supposed to be
shy and quiet but on the other hand they
can be eccentric and energetic however
in both cases they are deep thinkers and
highly intellectual people who love
helping others this definitely sounds
like to you who was shy at first but
after becoming friends with her bucco
promised to make a conscious effort to
make friends with the students of ua nua
she had to start from square one because
hobbico went to a different school and
as far as we know 2 is the only you a
student to come from salty Banks middle
school su u also has a vacant stare most
of the time making it hard for people to
know what she's thinking or feeling
which is not the most useful attribute
to have when trying to make friends but
on the other hand I'm sure she'd make a
great poker player and that's it for
this video guys thank you so much for
watching don't forget to united states
of smash that like button if you enjoyed
the video and subscribe for more MHA
videos also let me know which MHA
character you would like to see done
next in the comments you can also let us
know on Instagram and Twitter where
you'll find more MHA content and
discussion and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you